round one of the US and US women's Chess
Championships here in st. Louis they
were off to the races in the nation's
premier event as 24 of the best players
in the country descended on its chess
capital to fight for a national title
naazy but kids he had revenge on her
mind for last year's lost against the
youngster Jennifer you and the 2016
champ seal the deal to score a big win
50-year old anyway miss qualifying for
last year's competition but she didn't
miss a beat against fellow teenager
Maggie Fang and now finds herself in a
two-way tie for first
Wesley so had a wild game against st.
Louis residents Yaroslav era book but
the reigning champion put his stamp on
the end game to score a nice win to
start off the event it was the Battle of
the veterans between firuzan a Cobian
and newly minted hall-of-famer
Alex and honest jokes but it was Barr
who finally defeated his longtime rival
to join Wesley so atop the leaderboard
with the butterflies out of the way the
players are settling into the battle
ahead ground to action starts right now